im namen der heiligen barbara
wir sind das aufklärungs und
artilleriebataillon vier diskutiert in
allen steigt hier am dultplatz und den
horn wir bestehen aus zwei
aufklärungskampagnen zu schließenden
artillerie katrin und einer
stabskompanie und haben zur zeit hier im
rahmen dieser übung eingesetzt eine biz
batterie sowie eine aufklärungskampagne
und die stabskompanie zur durchführung
der versorgung wir sind auch mit stelle
eingesetzt
[Musik]
das aufklärungs und artillerie partie
und 4 stellt die aufklärung war sie die
augen sowie die stelle vorher
unterstützung der hammer für die vierte
panzergrenadierbrigade sicher
zurzeit führen wir her und mittels platz
1 patrick gewissen einer panzer bis
batterie durch
ziel dieser übung ist es unter
realitätsnahen bedingungen quasi
gefechts rahmenbedingungen feuer
anforderungen der kampftruppe so rasch
als möglich und so präzise als möglich
abzuarbeiten
[Musik]
das besondere an dieser übung ist dass
wir auch mit stylus sowohl bei der
artillerie als auch bei der aufklärung
eingesetzt haben und wir als aufklärungs
und datenreport der und vier sehr sehr
froh sind diese kameraden immer bei uns
begrüßen zu dürfen